>> Bret: THANKS, PETER.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S STORY WITH THE
TOP REPUBLICAN IN THE HOUSE,
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY IS WITH US.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Bret:
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" MOVES
THIS STORY TODAY.
REPORTING TRUMP REPEATEDLY
PRESSURED UKRAINE TO INVESTIGATE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
JOE BIDEN'S SON, URGING VLADIMIR
ZELINSKI EIGHT TIMES TO WORK
WITH RUDY GIULIANI, HIS PERSONAL
LAWYER, DO YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THAT?
>> JUST AS YOU SAID LAST NIGHT
WE NEED TO KNOW MORE FACTS.
THIS IS JUST BEING WRITTEN IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
WHAT DID WE SEE LAST WEEK WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WRITING
BEFORE THEY HAD ALL THE FACTS?
THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE, THE ACTING
DIRECTOR IS GOING TO BE BEFORE
THE INTEL COMMITTEE NEXT
THURSDAY IN A PUBLIC HEARING.
I THINK THAT WILL BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO FIND THE
INFORMATION OUT.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT SEEMED
TO SAY, HEY, LISTEN I CAN TALK
TO WORLD LEADERS HOWEVER I WANT
TO.
BUT YOU SHOULD LOOK INTO THIS.
YOU SEEM, WHEN TALKING TO
REPORTERS TODAY, WORRIED ABOUT
THE JOE BIDEN UKRAINE THING A
LOT MORE THAN YOU WERE WITH THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER THING.
IS THAT FAIR?
>> WHAT'S FAIR HERE IS THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE ABLE TO TALK
TO EVERY WORLD LEADER.
TONIGHT HE'S GOING TO HAVE THE
PRIME MINISTER FROM AUSTRALIA.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS.
BUT THINK FOR ONE MOMENT, ANY
CONVERSATION THAT YOU HAVE,
WHO'S LISTENING AND WHY ARE ALL
THESE OTHER PEOPLE LISTENING AND
ONLY SELECTIVELY TRYING TO PUT
SOMETHING OUT?
WE HAVE WATCHED THIS PATTERN
BEFORE GOING AFTER THIS
PRESIDENT, BECAUSE PEOPLE
DISAGREE WITH HOW THE OUTCOME OF
THE ELECTION TOOK PLACE.
I THINK THIS COUNTRY HAS GONE
THROUGH THREE YEARS OF THIS.
THIS PART HAS GOT TO STOP.
THE IDEA OF WHAT THEY ARE GOING
FORWARD.
LOOK, I'M CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT I
SAW ON THE VIDEO WHERE JOE BIDEN
HIMSELF, TELLING THE UKRAINE
GOVERNMENT, THAT THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO GIVE MONEY FROM THE
UNITED STATES IF THEY DON'T FIRE
A PROSECUTOR AND HE SAID
YOU'VE GOT SIX HOURS.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN SIX
HOURS?
THEY WERE FIRED.
THOSE ARE JOE BIDEN'S WORDS.
THAT IS CONCERNING TO ME.
>> Bret: IF THE PRESIDENT DID
AS IS BEING REPORTED,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" NOW DOES
MATCH "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
HE MENTIONED NUMEROUS TIMES TO
THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE WHILE
THE U.S. IS CONSIDERING
$250 MILLION IN AID TO UKRAINE,
IS THAT IMPLICIT QUID PRO QUO TO
GET THIS INVESTIGATION
KICK-START A?
>> YOU DON'T HAVE ANY OF THE
FACTS.
LET'S WAIT UNTIL NEXT THURSDAY.
LET'S GO THROUGH THE APPROPRIATE
CHANNELS.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE LEARNED
THIS LESSON BEFORE?
LET'S JUST SAY -- I'M NOT GOING
TO SPECULATE THAT IT HAPPENED.
>> Bret: LET ME JUST SAY,
WOULD SOMETHING LIKE THAT BE A
PROBLEM FOR YOU?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT WILL BE A
PROBLEM FOR ME?
FOR ME TO SPECULATE WITHOUT
KNOWING THE FACTS.
I WANT OUR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO HAVE RELATIONS
WITH EVERY COUNTRY.
I WANT OUR PRESIDENT TO BE ABLE
TO TALK TO THOSE LEADERS AND I
THINK IT IS INAPPROPRIATE THAT
ALL THESE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
LISTEN TO THESE CONVERSATIONS
AND SELECTIVELY PUT SOMETHING
OUT AND THEN HAVE ONE MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, WHEN EVERYBODY ELSE,
THE OTHER REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS IN THE INTEL
COMMITTEE, BUT ADAM SHAVED TO
TRY TO MAKE THIS POLITICAL?
REMEMBER WHAT ADAM SCHIFF SAID
TWO YEARS AGO BECAUSE MIKE THAT
HE HAD PROOF?
REMEMBER WHAT HE JUST PUT THE
COUNTRY THROUGH?
UNBELIEVABLE PAIN FOR SOMETHING
HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY TRUTH TO AND
HE MADE US GO THROUGH SO MUCH.
LET'S NOT MAKE THAT MISTAKE
AGAIN.
HAVE WE NOT LEARN FROM THE PAST?
DO WE NOW UNDERSTAND THAT THE
DEMOCRATS DID NOT LIKE THIS I
MIKE OUTCOME?
DID WE NOT KNOW THE ADAM SCHIFF
WAS PROVEN WRONG EVERY TIME
BEFORE AND IS HE DOING IT TO THE
COUNTRY BEFORE?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Bret: RIGHT, SO YOU'RE
ASKING FOR FACTS AND SO ARE YOUR
COLLEAGUES, BUT THEY ARE BEING
DENIED ACCESS TO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S COMPLAINT.
>> THEY ASKED TO HANDLE THIS IN
THE APPROPRIATE MANNER.
JUST AS THE LAW SAYS.
IF IT GOES TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL --
>> Bret: WHICH IS STANDARD.
>> NORMALLY THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
COULD COME TO CONGRESS BUT IN
THE INTEL COMMUNITY IT CAN GO TO
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL, WOULD
THEN GO TO THE D AND I, DIRECTOR
OF NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE, THE
ACTING DIRECTOR McGUIRE IS
HANDLING THIS, NOW HE'S COMING
BEFORE CONGRESS IN A PUBLIC
HEARING OF THE INTEL COMMITTEE
NEXT THURSDAY.
THAT'S THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO
HANDLE.
INSTEAD OF LEAKING, OR PUTTING
SOMETHING OUT BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO TURN THE STORY TO BE
DIFFERENT, JUST LIKE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DID LAST
WEEK.
>> Bret: YOU HEARD THE RUDY
GIULIANI BACK AND FORTH ABOUT,
NO I DIDN'T, YES I DID.
ASK THE UKRAINIANS TO
INVESTIGATE JOE BIDEN.
THERE IS A STORY HERE, A VERY
BIG STORY ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN
WORKING FOR THIS OLIGARCH IN AN
OIL COMPANY AND ALL OF THIS
BACKGROUND TO THIS INVESTIGATION
AND THEY ARE THERE APPEAR THE
REPORTER SAY THERE IS MORE TO
COME.
THAT IS WHAT YOU'RE POINTING TO.
>> MY POINT IS, AND JOE BIDEN'S
OWN WORDS, HE TELLS HOW HE
PRESSURED THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT THAT THEY WOULD NOT
GET FUNDING FROM AMERICA UNLESS
THEY FIRED A PROSECUTOR.
IT'S CONCERNING TO ME, THAT
PROSECUTOR INVESTIGATING HIS SON
AND HE SAID YOU'VE GOT SIX
HOURS?
AND WITHIN SIX HOURS THEY FIRED
HIM AND JOE BIDEN WAS PROUD OF
IT.
I ONLY LEARNED ABOUT THIS BY
JOE BIDEN TELLING US ABOUT IT.
>> Bret: YOU ARE SAYING THE
DNI'S GOING TO COME FORWARD WITH
INFORMATION?
>> I AM REAL CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
WOULDN'T IT BE INTERESTING
POLITICALLY IF YOU WANT TO
PEOPLE NOT TO LOOK AT WHAT BIDEN
WAS DOING TO TRY TO BRING
SOMETHING, ONCE AGAIN, ALLEGED
AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT AS THEY
HAVE DONE TIME AND AGAIN BECAUSE
THEY DON'T LIKE THE OUTCOME OF
AN ELECTION.
AND ISN'T IT INTERESTING THAT
ADAM SCHIFF WAS BEHIND IT AGAIN?
WHO LIED TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
THAT HE HAD PROOF, AND PUT US
THROUGH THE HORRIFIC TWO
YEARS --
>> Bret: YOU WANT TO PROVE,
WOULD YOU ADVISE THE PRESIDENT
TONIGHT AT THE STATE DINNER TO
PUT OUT THE TRANSCRIPT OF THAT
CALL?
>> WHAT I ADVISE THE PRESIDENT
TO DO IS BUILD A RELATIONSHIP
WITH AUSTRALIA BECAUSE IT IS SO
PIVOTAL TO OUR POINT FOR THE
NEXT CENTURY DEALING WITH CHINA
AND EVERYWHERE ELSE AND I THINK
THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN THROUGH
ENOUGH.
HE'S PROVEN HE CAN DO THE JOB
AND -- WHY ARE PEOPLE LISTENING
TO HIS CALLS QUESTION REQUIRED A
SELECTIVELY PUTTING SOMETHING
OUT FOR POLITICAL GAIN?
LET HIM GOVERN THIS NATION.
THIS WORLD IS SAFER BECAUSE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I WANT TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND I WANT
TO HAVE RELATIONS WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES.
>> Bret: I WANT TO ASK YOU A
QUICK LIGHTNING ROUND.
IS THERE ANY CHANCE OF WINNING
BACK THE HOUSE?
>> THERE IS NOT ONLY CHANCE, IS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED IN
NORTH CAROLINA AND LOOK AT WHAT
IS GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN WE WIN
BACK THE HOUSE, THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY WILL ONLY BE STRONGER.
THE ONLY RETIREMENT I'M AFRAID
TO HAPPEN WAS WILL HURD.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT ALL THE
OTHERS, TWO YEARS AGO TED POE
RETIRED AND I WAS VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT BUT YOU KNOW WHO WON?
DAN CRENSHAW, THE NAVY SEAL.
HE HAS AN AMAZING FOLLOWING
TODAY.
WE HAVE, WESLEY HUNT, A
WEST POINT GRADUATE, THE NUMBER
OF CANDIDATES THAT WE HAVE WE
HAVEN'T SEEN IN THE PAST AND IF
I WERE THE DEMOCRATS, I WOULD BE
AFRAID BECAUSE THERE ARE 31
DEMOCRATS WHO SIT IN SEATS THAT
TRUMP CARRIED IN THAT RACE IN
NORTH CAROLINA, NINE, AND A 2018
WE WON IT BY 900 VOTES.
WE JUST 1 MEGABYTE 4100.
THAT SIMPLE 2% CHANGE IS 13
SEATS ON ITS OWN.
>> Bret: A LITTLE BIT MORE
LIGHTNING.
HERE WE GO.
FULL-BLOWN IMPEACHMENT EFFORT.
WOULD THAT HELP YOUR REELECTION
EFFORTS IN THE HOUSE?
>> I DON'T LOOK AT POLITICS BUT
I THINK IT WOULD ONLY HURT THE
COUNTRY.
JERRY NADLER, THAT IS ALL HE
WANTS TO DO BUT NOBODY ELSE
CARES FOR IT SO I THINK IT IS
STUPID.
>> Bret: IS NANCY PELOSI'S
LEADERSHIP IN JEOPARDY WITH THE
SQUAD ALL CALLING FOR IMPEACHMET
SQUAD ALL CALLING FOR IMPEACHME?
>> NANCY PELOSI IS THE SPEAKER
IN NAME ONLY.
SHE DOES NOT HAVE THE POWER.
THEY WERE ON THE FLOOR.
>> Bret: YOU MET WITH
MARK ZUCKERBERG TODAY.
ANY INSIGHTS GROUP?
>> WE HAD A GREAT CONVERSATION
WHEN IT COMES TO PRIVACY.
I HAVE A REAL CONCERNED ABOUT
PRIVACY.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO BREAK UP
COMPANIES OR MAKE THEM
UTILITIES, WHICH IS TERRIBLE FOR
AMERICA.
WHAT I WANT TO DO, PROTECT YOUR
DATA, LET YOU MOVE YOUR DATA,
LET YOU DELETE YOUR DATA.